I'm Alex Lyon and you're about to start
a seven-part mini-course on Concise,
Clear, and Confident Communication. I put this course together because I believe
It's really the best first step for you
in your professional development, laying
that foundation to develop strong
communication skills. Moving forward I
encourage you to watch all seven lessons.
There's a little practice involved in
each one so you can actually hear and
then try the ideas out. Let's jump right
into the first lesson.
In lesson one we're going after long-windedness.
I encourage you to watch this and go
through as many times as you need to to
make this material a habit. Tip one. Long-
windedness is a key enemy of good
communication. I'm always surprised that
really talkative people assume that
they're good communicators. But, more
talking does not equal good
communication. In fact, a lot of times if
these words--gabby, chatty, verbose, and
talkative--accurately describe you
it's probably forming a bad impression.
Especially in professional settings
Alison Green said it like this. You might
think well some people long winded but
it doesn't mean he wouldn't do a good
job.
The problem is that a minimum is signals
that you're not good at picking up on
conversational cues and it raises doubts
about your ability to organize your
thoughts and can convey needed information
quickly. So, strategy one, resolve why you
sometimes talk too much. When do you find yourself multiplying words being overly
talkative? Is it just at work or is it
social situations? And, what are your in-
the-moment thought processes that
trigger it?
Are you insecure about something? What's going on in your mind that's driving
that over talkative habit? Because all
the tips in the world will not undo an
unspoken belief that drives that
long-windedness. So, excessive
talkativeness is rooted in our unspoken
beliefs
let's say you're a physician and you're
thinking to yourself, maybe you don't
realize it, but you're thinking I want
people to know I'm smart. You will most
certainly talk too much to prove that.
And because we live in a polite society,
people just play along. But inside
they're having an entirely different
thought process about this conversation.
They will almost never tell you directly that you're long-winded however they will form
unfavorable impressions of you anyway.
And so it's very important to realize
the impact that long-winded
communication can have on your
professional relationships and the
people around you. So people are long- winded
for various reasons. What's your reason?
Maybe there's more than one. Is it
insecurity? Maybe some self-centeredness?
Do you want to show everything you know
like you're that physician? Do you like the
air time and attention? In other words,
does it feel good when people are
listening to you and you love when
everyone's watching you in action? Do you
mistake talking for adding value? Do
mistake more talking for good
communication? Are there some control
issues going on in your heart, in your
mind? In other words, do you like to
steer a conversation and be the one
talking so you dictate the pace and the
flow of things. Any one of these reasons,
and there are many others, could be
driving that long-windedness. So, it's
really important that you take some time
and get to the bottom of it.
Strategy number two is to gauge your
long-windedness. Usually there are
places and times when you're not
necessarily long-winded and other times you are.
Strategy two is to gauge your long-windedness. Rate yourself on a scale of 1 to
10. If you're really concise, give
yourself a 1. If you're somewhere in the middle,
depending on situation, 5. If you're
really long-winded, a 10. And, of course,
you can give yourself other scores. But I
would recommend setting a goal to move
at least below 5. Let's say you want
to be from a 1 to 4 range, depending upon
the situation. Concise strategy number
three is to commit to conciseness. As FDR
said be sincere, be brief, and be seated.
He's talking about presentations, it
sounds like. But I think this demonstrates
his commitment to conciseness. Because
conciseness really sets the stage for
that clarity and that confidence that
we're all after. And so commitment in
this sense means practicing the tips in
this video in the next six lessons. And
while you're doing and remember why you
want to be concise, clear, and confident.
Here are some reasons. People will pay
attention to what you say when you
communicate this way. People remember
what you say. You'll have more impact. And
you can lead more effectively. So there
are lots of good reasons to do so.
So, long-winded this is a key enemy to good communication. Some take-away strategies.
Resolve why you sometimes talk too much. Then gauge your long-windedness to
help you set that goal. And, then commit
to practicing the tips in this lesson
and the remaining six lessons. So your
first step is get to the bottom of your
unspoken reasons for long-windedness. That will really catapult you through this
course and help you apply these tips
with much more effectiveness. Looking
forward, we'll work on how to form a
concise overall message, concise
sentences, we'll work on organizing your
thoughts, effective pauses, avoiding
fillers, and confident nonverbals. If you
haven't yet subscribed to this channel,
Communication Coach, I encourage you to do so. And I look forward to seeing you
in the next lesson.